[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الاخبار افاد
مراسل الجزيره قبل قليل بان قوات كبيره من
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تتوغلوا في هذه
الاثناء في مدينه جنين ومخينها وقد افاد
مراسلنا بتسجيل سماع ذوي اطلاق نار ووقوع
اشتباكات بين مقاومين وقوته الاحتلال التي
تقتحم المخيم
ما الذي يحدث في هذه الاثناء
واضح ان هذا التوغل جزء من التغول
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتواصل في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه ما يجري في مخيم جنين منذ نصف
ساعه تقريبا لان قوات كبيره كانت قد توغلت
فيها وتوجهت الى اطرافه مخيم مدينه جنين
في الجهه الغربيه
الجنوبيه وهناك اشتباكات داره مع
مقاومينها فلسطينيين شهود العيان وايضا
الزميل عليه سمودي اكدوا لنا انهم شهدوا
سيارات الاسعاف ايضا تندفعوا باتجاه
المنطقه التي تقع فيها الاشتباكات القوات
التي توغلت وصلت الى اطراف المخيم من عده
محاور من عدهات
والاشتباكات الدائره في تلك المنطقه لكن
اللافت هذه المره ان قوات الاحتلال كانت
قد دخلت في الفتره تقريبا الذي يبدا فيها
الطلبه بالتوجه الى المدارس ولذلك وزاره
التربيه والتعليم اضطرت الى الاعلام عن
ارجاء
المدارس الى همم الى فتره متاخره هذا جزء
من ما شهدته بعض المناطق الفلسطينيه
الاخرى كان هناك تواغلات ايضا واقتحامات
واعتداءات على مناطق كثيره وهناك حمله
اعتقالات حتى الان لم تتضح مدائها بشكل
نهائي لكن بعد يوم امس وصباح هذا اليوم
يمكن الاشاره الى ان عدد الشهداء
الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه هذا العام قد ارتفع
الى 20 شهيدا بينهم خمسه من الاطفال وانا
نحو نصفهم من منطقه جنين بمفردها همم واضح
بان همم القوات الاحتلال تصعد من هجماتها
خاصه بعد المديح الذي يقيله الوزراء في
هذه الحكومه وهي حكومه اقصى اليمين
المتطرف
بالعنصريين لمن يقتل عربيا حيث ان وزير
الامن القومي سرعى بالامس ايضا الى امتداح
الذين قتلوا الشهيد في سلوان ومن قبله في
شعفاط وهكذا همم لذا التوغل في جنين حاليا
كما قلت هو جزء من هذا التغول المتواصل
وهو تصعيد متواصل ووفقه تقديرات فلسطينيه
واسرائيليه فانه ينذر ربما بسوء الطالع
وقد يقع يعني بما يعني انفجار على نطاق
واسع حاليا كما قلت في جنين ما زالت تدور
هناك اشتباكات مع مقاومين فلسطينيين هناك
حديث عن اصابات لكن الصوره لم تتضح لان
هذه التطورات هي في النصف ساعه الاخيره
فقط
بين مقاومين فلسطينيين او شبان فلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال كان هناك ربما وقت كافي
لتكون هناك رده فعل رسميا فلسطينيا
ماذا بهذا الشئ ردت الفعل الرسميه
الفلسطينيه او على صعيد الفصائل لا يبدو
انها ستختلف عن المرات السابقه هي في
طبيعتها تدعو الى توفير حمايه دوليه
للفلسطينيين اذانا كاسه حالي
هجمات والترهلات والاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
وايضا هناك بعض الفصائل التي تخرج
بالتحذير والانذار الاسرائيليين بان ذلك
قد يقودوا الى الى تصعيد مستمر واضح بان
الامور لا تقف عند هذا الحد المواجهه
الواقعه او الاستهداف الاسرائيلي الاحتلال
هو يستهدف الكل الفلسطيني بما فيه حتى
السلطه الفلسطينيه هناك بطبيعه الحال
ترتيبات لدى رئيس الوزراء اسرائيل الثانيه
ياهو لنقل السيطره على شؤون المدنيه في
سلطنه الحكم العسكري الاسرائيلي الى
الوزير اسمه مودريتش المعروف في تطرفه
والذي لديه مخطط وبرنامج يعمل عليه
لذلك نقل صلاحيات الى الوزير بين كبير
وهناك ايضا توعدات بتقويض السلطه
الفلسطينيه
وانهاء وجودها او على الاقل اضعافها
لتتحول لسلطه الخدميه فقط همم لافته بان
لدى الاسرائيليين في هذه الحكومه تحديدا
مشروعا يتجه نحو الحزم وهم يريدون السيطره
النهائيه على المنطقه سي وضمها الى
اسرائيل وتعزيزها بالاف من الوحدات
شكرا لك وليد العمري كنت معنا ايضا من رام
الله بهذا ينتهي المفاصل اللقاء